Uh
Huh.
What if this football,
field sized space rock and didn't make that term?
What does it get moving towards us?
We need disintegrate in our atmosphere.
If not,
how much time would we have to get out of the danger zone and just how big would
that danger zone be?
Clear plan to have any chance of surviving the collision is what if,
and here's what would happen if an asteroid hit.
The earth.
Asteroids are hitting the earth all the time.
Every day space bombards us with about a hundred tons of dust and sand.
Car size asteroids make it to our atmosphere about once a year they burn up in
the message sphere,
never reaching earth surface.
It's a massive 10 kilometer wide life threatening rocks like the one that wiped
out.
The dinosaurs don't come by too often,
maybe once every few million years.
The ones we do have to worry about are asteroids the size of a football field
that actually make it to earth.
Surface meteorites,
they tend to come down to earth every 2000 years.
What if one of those was to hit us tonight?
The extent of an asteroid's devastation to our planet all comes down to where it
lands.
Just 3% of our surface is populated.
That means in all likelihood,
97 asteroids out of 100 we'll just plunge into the ocean or flatten an
uninhabited forest somewhere in Siberia or northern Canada,
but three out of 100 asteroids would strick a populated city.
Imagine seeing a 100 meter long rock speeding towards you traveling at 30
kilometers per second.
From the moment it past unharmed through the mesosphere,
it would take less than three seconds to crash down to earth.
For a city like New York,
that would mean over two and a half million casualties.
A huge fireball would destroy everything in a three kilometer radius and cause
heavy damage to buildings within a seven kilometer radius.
Maybe it's not all bad,
ever hear of the media,
right?
That slammed into the Russian city of Jellybeans.
That rock exploded with the force of 20 Hiroshima bombs and cost around $33
million worth of damage.
Well,
in our scenario,
the media right is five times bigger.
The freshly fallen space rock may pose the risk of whites,
red radiation.
If it were made up of radioactive heavy metals,
of course it wouldn't be as bad as a 10 kilometer wide ass right hitting the
earth.
In that case,
the shockwave would be enough to wipe out a good chunk of humanity right away.
The earth would get a new crater over a hundred kilometers across and a ring of
asteroid debris would give us a Saturn like appearance.
Most of this debris would rain back down on earth setting cities and forest on
fire and cooking everything that's not protected.
You might want to invest in an underground bunker before this happens because on
the surface it will be very,
very dusty.
All this Dustin smoke would block the sunlight without the sun.
All plants and a lot of animals would die out
after about a year if the atmosphere would clear up,
but there would be very little food left for humans and if we were resourceful
enough,
this will be the end of our race.
We would suffer the same fate as the dinosaurs did 65 million years ago.
The good thing is we have the atmosphere to protect us from most asteroids and
NASA to keep an eye on all the space rocks flying around us.
Bad thing is it's sometimes hard to detect the incoming rock until it's too
late.
Tell us what you think.
Are you preparing for a sudden blast from space.